this is Jocko podcast number 233 with
echo Charles and me Jocko willing a good
evening echo good evening
so the last podcast we were reviewing a
book about the Buhler Wars and we're
gonna pick up where we left off last
time which is what the British did with
the lessons that they learned the
military reforms that they made and how
they how they made this transition and
then where it ended up in well in World
War one so the name of the book is the
Boer War and military reforms by J Stone
and Erwin Schmitt 'el and let's take it
back to the book so picking up where we
left off this is the this is what this
is when they start talking about the the
reforms that got made from the top down
appointments were made in a casual
random manner that often resulted in
matching of poor and poor matching of
personality skills or personal
inclinations inclinations to the demands
of a particular post so the way that
they were appointing officers was just
kind of random and then the way they
were matching up teams was also kind of
random and then you take the wrong
personalities and mix them together
you're not gonna end up with good
leadership continuing on it if locating
and assigning qualified officers to
proper posts proved a problem the same
must be said of the selection of
individual units and even private
soldiers what unit cohesion had existed
vanished quickly in South Africa
Littleton's division for no apparent
reason reasons shrank in a few weeks
from eight battalions to five and a half
regiments were broken up into smaller
units then reconstituted into mixed
battalions this was done with a seeming
disregard of structural and historic
uniformity with adverse consequences on
esprit de corps in an army with strong
wrench of mental ties so they take a
bunch of teams they get to South Africa
and they split them all up and mix them
all up this is just a bad move I used to
be
I used to feel like I was kind of
cheating a little bit when it came to
when it wouldn't task unit bruiser was
going through our pre-deployment workup
because I would we would we would train
we would split up and we'd mix up but
when we had to do a training operation
we'd kit in our units and we'd stick to
him for the most part because it was
just so much better yeah so much better
when you're working with people you work
with and and they just threw that out
the window here yeah wait you said you
felt like you're cheating yeah I felt
like I was cheating yeah because it will
it was so much more alike you know it
man it was just such an advantage and
they try and give us you know multiple
targets where it would where you could
kind of convince yourself that it would
be a good idea to take these guys and
move them over to this platoon and take
these and just no no we'll just stick
with the platoon integrity yeah and I'm
not saying that you shouldn't do
interoperability cuz you should and you
should be able to mix people up but you
should also have that kind of baseline
and there's a reason I think the
regimental historical Asprey decor
that's real hmm continue on
bureaucratically the system was a
nightmare as an official account of
manpower was awesome was sometimes lost
for months at a time the lack of
coherence was not due to want of
paperwork for if anything the pre-war
structure was overly centralized in in
1898 the Broderick Committee on
decentralization decentralization heard
testimony from the general commander
commanding and alder shop that it took
12 signatures including two orders from
London to return an unsatisfactory
driver so you got some micromanagement
going on some centralized command that's
never good fast-forward a little at
staff work with us fell on about 70
officers some well trained but many
useless although Pleasant aristocrats
Buller later claimed that in Pretoria I
found Roberts sitting in one building
with his Hindu staff Kitchener in
another with his Egyptian staff and
cally Kenney in a third with an English
staff all pulling against one another
with so many centres of control
functioning at once it should come as no
surprise
that time and again key points would be
left unguarded isolated battalions
unsupported or critically needed guns
unassigned the saving grace to an
otherwise chaotic system was Roberts
phenomenal memory and attention to
detail so you got these guys that have
their own little silo setup you know you
got Kitchener that'd that had worked in
Egypt and worked with the Egyptians and
he brought them into South Africa and
and same thing with with Roberts with
his Hindu staff they all had their own
little cliques that's not gonna work out
good you're not working together troops
and because of that fast-forward a
little at troops sometimes when hungry
Cavalry's lacked sometimes lacked horses
and hospital arrangements rarely proved
adequate kitcheners misunderstanding of
Staff principles was best demonstrated
when where when he wrote about the
battlefield imposing his will rather
than staying at his headquarters in
manifesting it through properly
organized staff channels so again that
means he doesn't trust his people he's
out there on the battlefield trying to
tell people exactly what to do and what
kind of oversight are you giving when
you're out there on the battlefield
barking orders at people to tell him
exactly what to do
not gonna work out well
Alan be summed up summed up the view of
a commander of a subordinate column by
noting one is always at high pressure
one is probably under the same general
for about a month at a time when he is
played about and knock one's column to
rags he goes off that's what the
subordinates were saying oh you're gonna
show up here for a month you're gonna
bark orders you're gonna yell at us tell
us do stephan1 we're all worn out you're
gonna bail the drawbacks of Kitchener's
system are obvious over centralization
isolation from the field and time lags
after a year of frustration Kitchener
agreed to the appointment of Ian
Hamilton as chief of staff this was an
admission that given the greater size
complexity and distances of Modern
Warfare coupled with extreme dispersion
of forces that no individual could
single-handedly run an entire war but
that was a year deep this is something
that worked then some I see a lot is
people that are
people that they're they're too
egotistical to say hey you don't need
some help I need a higher number - yeah
that's all of us
it's just ego kicking it they talk about
running of the railroad because that was
a big part and the British really didn't
have the capability they didn't have
that in their in their in their
capabilities of hey we needed we need to
run this rail the British military needs
to run a railroad and they didn't really
have that capability also circled one
note in here about the fact that what
Roberts ultimately did was resort of
having hostages civilians on the trains
to try and keep him safe interesting
advancement here the soldiers benefited
from the first individual field dressing
kits and identification cards this
information proof so you useful that in
1906 dog tags were introduced so there's
the introduction of dog tags in the
world I thought that was interesting
they also founded the Royal Army Medical
Corps so they they realized some of the
things that they needed to do from a
medical perspective another thing they
said here a major complaint of medical
officers was the enormous amount of red
tape surgeon spoke of an inability to
operate because of long hours spent
behind the desk check out this statistic
over the course of the war poor water
and sanitation were largely responsible
for an annual sickness rate of 958 men
per thousand so almost every single
person you are gonna get sick and
they're not reporting like a miner Colts
they're reporting hey this guy was out
of duty so that's why all the support
people out there that'll listen to this
all the military support people out
there doesn't happen if you're not there
logistics wins Wars you can't win a war
if everyone's sick
[Music]
fast forward a little bit in all the in
all areas that changes wrought by the
Boomer war or by no means limited to
higher organization nor to big-ticket
items such as larger guns Hospital ships
or armored chains trains many seemingly
minor changes occurred as well what
stand out are the changes in the mundane
items of soldierly life such as uniforms
and personal equipment perhaps the most
obvious of these was the evolution
toward uniformity of battlefield attire
among all types of troops this led to
the adoption of the India inspired khaki
color drill field uniforms by all except
the Highlanders economy in camouflage
potential became the new standard of
production yet it was only with the
widespread use of smokeless powder that
these qualities could take precedence
previously rapid-fire weapon tree had
been restricted by the heavy smoke that
would cover a battlefield under those
circumstances camouflage uniform seems
superfluous and needlessly unattractive
so this is where you start getting
camouflage uniforms because before
there'd be so much smoke on the field
that it was just pointless to even have
camouflage if no one could see you
anyways so you might as well look good
so if you're a Brit pre-war dress
standards in the British Army had always
emphasised excessive smartness to the
point of making it the most
unserviceable and unworkable in the
world in the eyes of some contemporaries
perhaps the most pernicious effect of
smartness so they had these really
nice-looking uniforms which were totally
unfunctional however there was a need to
discipline men to take cover
during pre-war training having to pay
for damaged uniforms discouraged ready
use the ground so these guys would have
these these uniforms that were so nice
that during training they wouldn't want
to get on the ground
regarding the rest of the kit whenever
possible is lightened including the
adoption of aluminum canteen first
developed in Germany so they're making
stuff flatter this is it this is why
some of these things this were you start
getting the first modern war you know
there's a couple Wars that you can talk
about that were the first modern war
these are some of the things that make
you start saying mmm this is these are
legit
movements are forward toward modern war
to outfit an entire army in the same
manner had advantages aside from ease of
supply and economy now this is this is I
made a quick note here I always talk
about decentralized right decentralized
command everything's that be
decentralized and does that being said
some things should be centralized and if
they're not centralized there's gonna be
problematic so for instance do we want
everyone in our platoon of 40 guys do we
want everyone to have different weapons
what do you think no no we do not we
want everyone to have the same weapon so
where we gonna get that weapon from a
centralized place the same so when we
all have the same weapon we all have the
same parts we all have the same
ammunition that's what we want we don't
want everyone carrying their own
different type of weapon uniform same
thing we want everyone to look the same
medical kit where is that medical kit
gonna go on your gear you want it in the
same spot so if you get shot I'd come
over I know where your medical kit is so
there's some things that absolutely have
to be centralized so occasionally like
I'll be working with a company and
there's someone that doesn't want to
kind of you doesn't want to use whatever
standard doesn't want to follow some
procedure and I always have to bring
this up you know that there's some
procedures absolutely have to be
centralized when you're in the Battle of
Ramadi you have near and far recognition
signals you want everybody to know what
those are you know and we had everybody
in Ramadi knew what the recognition
signal was from a long ways away we all
everybody knew Army Marine Corps every
one of the same thing believe me you
want that centralized you don't want 12
seals going out on an operation and they
have a different recognition signal than
the army guys yeah so yes there are
times when things must be centralized
of course fast-forward a little at the
essential piece of equipment for all
ranks and virtually all services was now
the rifle more potent powders and
improved smaller caliber bullet design
made possible higher velocities and more
precise shooting at ever-increasing
ranges so this is where using the rifle
that's what we're doing both sides
besides realize the potential of
bicyclists as the Brewers distribute a
company of cyclists among their generals
and the British called cyclists from
vary units various units and retrain two
full battalions out there on their on
their bikes getting after it imagine if
they had modern mountain bikes and you
know now they have the mountain bikes
with the electrical with the electric
boost have you seen those things John
Dudley the hunter
Archer he uses one of those things to
get out to different hunting locations
hmm why ferry it's quiet it's silent can
take it anywhere it's light it's viable
yeah it's totally viable communication
was perhaps when the most consistent
problems encountered in a swift moving
war fought over tens of thousands of
square miles of terrain for messages to
Europe
the oceanic cables sufficed but within
South Africa Telegraph cables were often
cut thus signal flags were used but had
limited ranges of eight kilometres and
transfer transfer rates of eight words
per minute much preferred was the
heliograph with a range of over 40 miles
on clear terrain and a speed of 12 words
per minute heliographs had the advantage
of being undetectable if not in direct
line-of-sight
what's a heliograph you might wonder
it's a mirror it's a mirror you're using
a little mirror to reflect them send
Morse code or whatever huh 40 miles you
gotta have some altitude to do that yeah
because the horizon is 12 miles big is
that what like this I have no idea went
three inches I think it's bigger and
must have been some kind of
machine with a little a more on it well
shoot if you're talking for miles
that's the fury miles forty minority
miles
oh yeah that's like huge then that's not
the kind you're carrying in your pocket
maybe not we'll have to go off to take a
historical look at the heliographs of
the past 40 40 miles it would have to be
trashcan size at least I think trashcan
lid everything be know could be look
into them can you imagine the number one
form of communication that you have is
using a mirror and reflecting it towards
your buddy
who's 40 miles away by the way this is
what 100 and 100 years ago 110 years ago
something like that and now we got an
iPhone in our pocket we can talk to
people in space wartime experience
clearly showed the need for better
equipment for reconnaissance
communication and ranging so there you
go those are some of the reforms now we
dip into a little bit a little bit more
tactical stuff during the course of the
Boer War every branch of the British
Army experimented experienced change and
nowhere was this more evident than in
tactics for the infantry the foremost
consideration was the enormous increase
in firepower proper maneuvering and
deployment which could lead to initial
superiority of position or psychological
advantage became even more important as
concentrated rapid fire had become so
devastating that once battle had been
joined it was nearly impossible to
rectify any initial ear errors without
suffering serious casualties battles
were now resolved at an uneven pace a
few minutes at a tactical disadvantage
could prove more decisive than hours of
marginal superiority what are we talking
about there what we're talking about is
all of a sudden if you got the tactical
advantage you were at a massive
advantage not a little one a massive one
and you could get yourself to a position
through five this speed surprise and
violence of action you could get if you
use speed surprise violence batching and
you got the advantage you are at
massive advantage a massive advantage
marksmanship was be cook fast forward a
little at marksmanship was becoming a
matter of soldier of selecting
individual targets and ranges rather
than collective mass volley fire and
this in turn necessitated a new type of
training for one as for his one boomer
noted of 35 men whom we took prisoners
after they had fired up to add us up to
350 pace paces not not a single one had
his site correct most of them had kept
their sites at eight hundred and eight
hundred fifty yards because no order to
change had been given that's centralized
that centralized command you're at 350
yards
can you imagine you're capturing by the
way just in case you don't know this
when you have your site set for eight
hundred and fifty yards or eight hundred
yards and you're shooting at someone
that's three hundred hours away you're
not going to hit them mmm that's not
happening you're gonna miss them so
imagine you come you capture your your
opponent and there don't even have their
their site set and you ask them why not
well we didn't get ordered too crazy you
know keep you keep your weapons doped in
is what I'm saying
the British infantry drill of 1896 had
placed too little emphasis on the
firefight and too much on depth of
formations at clen so the Brewers were
outnumbered four to one yet less than a
third of the British Army was involved
in the attack the Boers understood
modern small arms captain Reichman an
American military observer noted I did
not learn of any case when the Brewers
had determined to hold their ground that
the frontal attacks succeeded by its own
power
so what are we hearing right here we're
gonna hear it a little but that flanking
movement coming in to play big time
never heard of the frontal attack
working am I gonna tell you the frontal
attack never works I'm not gonna tell
you that I'm gonna tell you though you
best be leaning towards flanking
maneuvers the futility of the old
attacks and frontal assault was
compounded by an infantry termed
by the times by the times history as
being in different shots careless of
cover slow to comprehend what was taking
place or to grasp the whereabouts of the
enemy always surprised her loss how
helpless without their officer in a word
well disciplined but ill trained one
might say untrained think about those
descriptions how would you like your
military unit to be described as in
different shots you can't hit anything
careless of cover you're not you're not
protecting yourself slow to comprehend
what was taking place needs no
explanation or to grasp the whereabouts
of the enemy you don't even know where
the bad guys are always surprised or
lost that's a nightmare helpless without
their officer these are the worst
description like amongst the worst
descriptions that you can give and then
what's interesting says in order well
disciplined and you know me disciplines
at the top of my list but if you're so
well disciplined but you can't think for
yourself you're worthless hmm the
provisional the provisional course of
musketry for the year 1902 took the bold
step of abolishing the volley so now
we're not gonna get online anymore and
shoot on command as well as encouraging
fire from cover and the use of any kind
of rest natural or artificial zone now
that's the first little step there
ticket and I want you to pay attention
it's a little bit 1902 so now they're
starting to take the lessons from the
Boer War and say okay guess what we need
to learn how to fire from cover when you
start shooting individually and the
reason I say pay attention to that date
is that they're gonna make changes and
then they're gonna regress back then and
they're gonna go to what you know it's
like you know when you get the you get
the wrestler and he's going against a
Sikh jiu-jitsu guy and you say look
don't take this guy down you got better
hands and then he gets caught with a
little shot and what does he do takedown
goes right back to what he kind of knows
it's a trap yeah it's a trap your habits
are a trap
[Music]
continuing on the defense's increased
power drastically reduced troop
densities so how many people do we have
on the battlefield we're starting to
spread out Wellington had fought
Waterloo with 69 thousand men on a
two-mile frontage the Boomers had held
their friend front with only 300 men to
the mile
did you hear that 69 thousand for two
miles and three hundred men to a mile
that's how much different it was that's
how dispersed they got continuing on a
little bit larger more dispersed
battlefields destroyed the ability of a
single general to command a battle and
even in the most broad of terms I'm
gonna say that again larger more
dispersed battlefields destroyed the
ability of a single channel to command a
battle even in the most broad of terms
so you got all these people they're
spread out over 300 miles Howard and you
got to communicate with a freaking
mirror right you're not gonna so what
you need to learn how to use
decentralized command you need to learn
how to give commander's intent greater
alliance had to be put on lower echelon
officers and NCOs frequently
non-professional officers were expected
to lead by personal example in battle
this disproportionate their
disproportionate losses testified to
this role under South Africa's fluid
battle conditions small unit command
became more critical and this is the
same way the military is now you can't
expect a platoon commander that's out
there in the Battle of Ramadi he's out
there he's not he's making decisions
he's making calls at least that's the
way it should be
does this communication modern
communications start to allow for
micromanagement to take place yes it
absolutely does which one
our alpha - what direction are you
moving I want you to move 200 meters to
the north technical to 200 degrees north
after that you know that's what can
happen nowadays it's not good in
self-protection and for the good of the
army officers began to leave their
Countryman's behind and play a less
conspicuous role in advance so now we're
not wearing our you know our badges that
say were in charge
role models such as bowler who remained
in the thick of the fighting at Killeen
so until wounded became a thing of the
past
senior officers now kept further to the
rear and the tactical role of junior
officers was enhanced in the early
months of the war the British were
fortunate and that their unique
organizational pattern of eight small
companies per battalion allowed them to
have sufficient complement of officers
to weather the heavy early losses but
yes so now we're moving more toward
decentralized command interestingly it
was the volunteers and militia so the
volunteers in militia if you remember
these are like the reservists people
that were doing part-time they proved
most adaptable to new forms of warfare
probably because of their closer ties to
the civilian mode of thinking they have
open minds at the bottle of dorm come
the City of London Imperial volunteers
advanced by rushes and used covering
fire while the Gordon's were still
moving in forward and relatively dressed
light cover move I love getting to the
root of things mm-hmm like it that's
that's it that incredible you have these
civilians that are reservists and they
go hey guess what you shoot I'll move mm
they ain't been taught that they figured
it out you shoot I'll move when I get in
a good spot I'll shoot you move ready go
meanwhile the pros the Gordon's were
already all rise all forward march
that's what they're doing yeah it's like
their their creativity was trained out
of them or something creativity was try
not always have to give that warning
about discipline inside of a unit
because if you have so much discipline
inside of a unit people stop thinking
yeah and that's the last thing as a
leader that's the last thing you want
last thing you want anywhere right you
have a company you don't want people
doesn't stop thinking about how to do
things better you have a jiu-jitsu
school you want everyone just to learn
the moves that you teach them and not
think of anything no yeah
creativity should be nurtured creativity
should be watered should grown and and
and and reward it you know I keep
thinking back to that when he just said
about like they didn't adjust their
sights because they weren't ordered to
so you ever watch coming to America so
yes so that in the beginning he was
already Murphy and in Murphy Arsenio
Hall yes sir so he was gonna get married
what do you call it a arranged marriage
marriage where the his wife is gonna be
like the ultimate servant wife right and
essentially she was like those people
not adjusting the sights because they
were in order to because because this
lady was gonna do everything like
everything that he wanted every single
thing and she proved it or whatever just
real briefly he kind of kind of waited
notice this little part but it made it
kind of basically the same point so this
movie had a lasting impact on your
philosophies continue I'm telling you
those nuggets and Easter eggs in there
all in there so he was like hey so
you're gonna do everything you know he
was okay let me talk to you for a minute
right in the middle of the marriage
ceremony I'm gonna talk to you from in
the back room whatever and he's like
she's like yeah your service whatever
and he's like hey um so I want to get to
know you and she's like yeah I've just
been raised to serve you he's like what
kind of stuff you like she's like
whatever you like
she's like thing it's like so anything I
tell you to do you'll do she's like yep
it's like anything I tell you what
you'll do she's like yep
like happy too so he's like hey bark
like a dog starts barking like a dog
think hoot like orangutan or something
like this
she started doing he so Joe hop on one
leg she starts doing it all at once
right and he's like all confused his dad
walks in it's like oh you guys are
getting along whatever and he's like um
he's like oh please excuse us to the
wife right meanwhile she's still
you know one Lake and hooting like our
Ranga Tang still didn't get ordered to
stop that's why he's like hey can you
excuse us you'd think she'd be like okay
thanks and walk out she hops out still
doing the Ranga thing thing
you seem saying she didn't get ordered
to stop the same thing even though it'd
be kind of common knowledge but she was
trained her whole life to follow his
orders I'm saying same thing it's
interesting that that scene from that
movie from 1984 486 or whatever has just
been floating around in your brain
waiting to get grabbed on I'm Jim by the
pool warm and the London Imperial
volunteers yes same thing well their
creativity versus the Gordon's who are
just hopping on one leg and hooting Mike
her anger tanks yeah or what happens
they were ordered yeah well the point
there is these concepts are everywhere
you got to watch out yeah what I'm
saying so I'm with you
be careful the just like was that Eddie
Murphy's character or Arsenio Hall's
character in that scene yes Eddie Murphy
just like Eddie Murphy didn't want
someone that lacked creativity you as a
leader do not want people that just are
gonna follow orders yeah I know it's
hard to understand that but it's true
yeah after watching that movie
understand it more clear for sure but
that's what was part of the point though
of the movie literally your your analogy
is proofed by all authority Susie at
present continuing on the agile infantry
of 1900 the average the agile
infantryman of 1901 who ran and crawled
across the battlefield relatively
unencumbered by bulky equipment and
directed primarily by whistles was in
marked contrast to the 1893 image of the
professional soldier which still
pervaded many of the regulations so by
1901 they had advanced they were they
were moving they were they were
traveling lighter advances were now made
under the cover of Rolling barrage and
was that that's when you're launching
artillery of people so the other
the enemy gets their head down and
that's how you're gonna move that's
cover move first demonstrated at the
Battle of Peters Hill early earlier
methods that depended on accurate low
angle of fire of shrapnel and high
explosives on enemy positions proved
ineffective the avoidance of independent
a frontal attacks wherever possible
became matter of universal consensus as
presented in infantry drill so they have
by the end of the war realized frontal
attacks no good psychological
preparation for the bayonet assault went
far beyond the military training and was
reflected in numerous contemporary
accounts and drawings that such
occurrences were rare was of little
relevance interesting the Brewers
claimed contempt for cold steel as no
position or piece of terrain seemed
worth dying for Europeans used to
fighting in far more restricted areas
under strict discipline would on
occasion stand and defend a position to
the death so this is that will the weird
thing that they they they kept they kind
of kept this idea behind the bayonets in
the cold steel so there's an American
journalist named Julie and Ralph and he
had this little quote we have learned
that even British valor displayed by a
number of men equal to the foe is of no
conclusive value under the new condition
and that if all modern armies could
entrench themselves and then and could
then compel their enemies to meet them
in frontal attack war would be abandoned
as soon as possible our sorry it would
be abandoned as impossible what are you
saying there is if you could get your if
you could get in an entrenched position
and get your enemy to attack you war
would be abandoned because it would seem
it's impossible you're not going to be
able to take out these positions not
against and and and what's crazy this is
what World War one is entrenched
positions attack it doesn't work at
range position attack doesn't work
doesn't work doesn't work
and this guy this American journalist is
saying this in in you know 1902
previously the British were hesitant to
adopt field entrenchments despite
numerous contemporary experiences to the
contrary they feared that a defensive
psychology bred by reliance on
fieldworks and by field works they mean
trenches and ditches and foxholes did
not bode well for a victorious army like
that's a that's a negative attitude
that's Patton right we're not digging in
that means we're defending we're not
defending we're going on offense Bullers
famous pre-war jack-in-the-box
memorandum at which i look for I
couldn't find it is perhaps the most
indicative of the English way of War
battles he felt could not be won by
officers or men who ducked in action
think about that that's when you're
telling your MMA fighter hey bro don't
you need to just go out there and throw
punches and if you get hit that's part
of it
mmm that's how you win cuz you're a man
don't you don't need to you don't need
to move you don't know don't worry about
head movement yeah pre-war Army
Regulations recognize two types of
entrenchments the half hour and the one
hour type both of which were earth
embankments and the one hour and what
the one and a half feet high differing
and with so the only they only had the
most you're gonna dig it in half an hour
you can't dig an effective foxhole and a
half an hour it's not happening
the British infantrymen did not even
carry a shovel and was a customs /
regulations to Native laborers or
engineering building any necessary
entrenchments the final proof of this
change in doctrine was the issuance of
shovels to two-thirds of the infantry
and light picks to the remainder by 1903
so by 1903 they realized you know what
all you got to give two thirds these
guys shovel the other guys we got two
pickaxes entrenching tools
in his ironic how many of the wars
lessons for infantry could have been
learned during peacetime be they the
value of well-constructed entrenchments
or lightened combat loads the enhanced
difficulty of reconnaissance or the new
dangers of the fire zone the misplaced
faith in the firing line is
self-sufficient protection at long
ranges or the essential nature of the
turning movement in combination with all
frontal attacks if they would have
trained that saying if they would have
trained harder they would have been able
to figure a lot of this stuff out now as
they looked at this it's as a quote here
the bulk of the British officers
preferred to believe that failure was
due to a lack of training and discipline
so we start to get back we start to head
back in the wrong direction that saying
hey look if our guys would have been
more disciplined then they could have
they could they could have done better
mmm we're not quite so a hundred percent
sure about that it's it's the idea of
you know what a jujitsu move isn't
working like if if I'm showing you foot
walk mm-hmm and you're you're saying hey
the guy you know the guy's not tapping
mm-hmm and I look at your foot lock and
I say do it harder that's my that's my
recommendation yeah same deal it's not
good yeah go Harger is not an effective
way of correcting something that isn't
working I haven't I run this with
businesses businesses will show me their
the strategy that they're using their
marketing plan their growth plan or
whatever and it's not working mm-hmm and
I said well so what are you gonna do now
what we're gonna do it yeah we're gonna
put more money into we're gonna do a
harder look sometimes do you need to ok
overwhelming force sure but sometimes
you got to look at that and say wait we
really haven't gotten a anywhere and now
we're just gonna go harder pour more
assets into this and squeeze harder on
the foot how hard should you have to
squeeze on the foot for it to work
there's a different mistake that you're
making let's figure out what that is mmm
yes when is the time
to go harder maybe when it's kind of
work yeah that's what I'm saying what
our girl why are you getting because if
I'm if you're if you're putting a foot
lock on me and I'm not barely even
reacting to it mmm we're judging that as
ineffective yeah and you start to
squeeze hard maybe I maybe I feel it a
little bit but I'm barely still not even
reacting if you see me start to react
yeah what do you always say when you get
a when you get some little moment of
beauty with me you always got a sense of
her defensive version so if you see a
sense of urgency
you know you think okay maybe I could go
a little bit harder and make that make
something happen there yeah then it does
feel like it depends kind of on how hard
you're going to begin with because if
you're maxing out and I sense a slight
sense of urgency I'm like man yeah I go
harder that's might not be you know
might be diminishing returns on that one
so it's like so yes contrast your output
if your ROI and see if you should just
go harder sometimes it's face it Brad
just go harder and it'll work you know
yeah yeah yeah sometimes it does but
there's probably a mistake that you're
making right most jujitsu moves you
shouldn't have to you shouldn't have to
you shouldn't get tired doing a
jiu-jitsu submission yeah right yeah I
mean occasionally you like maybe some
weird choke that your grip is getting
tired yeah or even like in a competition
where you're kind of like maybe like
you're focusing too hard on conservation
or something like this and this guy is
kind of picking up the pace on you and
it's a competition so it's like you know
a different environment you know in a
way and then yeah so maybe go a little
bit harder even then it's like man you
could you could think your way through
that you know unless you're admittedly
admittedly being lazy mmm then you could
need to go harder at least a little bit
when you're gonna go harder you have to
make sure that the direction that you're
going is gonna be fruitful yeah
you ever when you're training like you
get like let's say someone's on sure you
know what you know you know I do this to
kind of Greg training sure dick he'll
get a good
he put a bow and arrow choke on me and I
mean it was legit like he and I had you
know I had like a little bit of his G
and a little bit of my geek yeah and I
just sat there and you know he went in
here and are doing like six minute
rounds yeah and he got it pretty quick
mm-hmm you know he got it within let's
say probably within two or three minutes
so he had three or four minutes of me
yeah and I just kind of had that you
know bit down and kind of flex my neck
and I'm holding his key and my key
yeah and I had I had pretty good grips
on both you know what I mean like you
know you happen to get like the I happen
to get a good grip and great training
admittedly is smaller than me as well
but he went hard harder for four minutes
mm-hmm and let's face it what is the
drop dead time for a bow narrow choke to
work like at what point do you say hey
it's been 45 seconds and this guy did
not tap and I put my knee in his back
and I'd arched hard and I pulled hard
and this guy didn't tap the rest of
probably from 45 seconds on is a waste
of energy
yes especially if you're pull if you're
if you're maxing out the strategy is to
pull you know like that's it right there
I mean that's not counting like you know
cuz you can make adjustments and make
you take like a good three minutes
sometimes let me adjust here try okay I
didn't work it entered the submission
attempt no
he had entered a submission this was to
make me tap yeah I just sat there and so
anyways I can't remember if he held on
till that the round ended hmm I don't
think he did I think you know with 30
seconds left he let go and we you know
but he was just done after that he was
so gassed he was gassed like he just did
of 20 minute metcon check your ROI
whatever man I can't I can't help but
kind of relate to him a little bit cuz
you get into that position where the
Mangala submissions in on Joc oh shoot
you think I'm gonna risk adjusting or no
no no I'm going for it
straight up I'm be lining for that
submission you're just gonna maintain do
or die but seriously you get me in a bow
and arrow choke and there's it's been 45
seconds yeah think about how long 45
seconds is yeah that's a long time yeah
and it doesn't work you're gonna keep
pulling no not you no not at all but I
am saying that I can relate with the
attitude for sure the well I wonder did
he see you did you did he see that you
had that grip yeah yeah so a lot of
times yeah after the 45 seconds you're
like product grip is jamming me up so
that's the issue the issues in my choke
it's that grip right there how good of a
job did I do of giving him a false sense
of hope that's right like how much did I
go yeah right how much did I like give
that to him where he's thinking it must
be close and they're not close yeah
that's such an interesting strategy I do
that with laying just laughs do you
knows that our mine yeah well sometimes
when you do it it's like you have a tone
of condescending I just you I when I do
it to you I absolutely will have a tone
of condescending I'm I'm just saying
your move is ineffective yeah
you know and Yahoo yeah Brett's my
torment mission back to the book there
was this is fast-forward there was
however one aspect of British
pacification policy that did cast
lasting disgrace upon their methods the
concentration camps the military gave
three pretext for their existence first
they were meant to protect the isolated
bore families whose men had gone off to
fight second they were meant to separate
the commandos from the supplies and
intelligence that their families could
provide and third it was claimed that
the subsequent isolation would force the
burghers to surrender 28,000 whites and
14,000 Africans died in these camps of
various diseases the reasons for this
disaster were many again modern war this
is our first real look at at
concentration camps and you know I I
don't know I don't know what the intent
is and we'll have to study more to find
out the intent I could see both sides I
could see the intent of being those
things that they talk about hey we
wanted to protect them we wanted to keep
their supply lies separate like I could
see that as the intent I can also see
intent as we've been here for two and a
half years and we're not winning and
we're gonna break that or will to fight
by by killing them by putting in these
in these camps and making their lives
miserable for their families that's a I
mean in that that's I don't know what 27
movies you're about to bring up but you
know the Moot where the movie is like
hey you know the cops ready to ready to
you know do something the bad guy and
then they pull pull up in the car and
there's the bet there's the cops kid
right like hey if they go to the family
and that's what breaks the guy that's
what makes him have to comply so it
seems like maybe and again I don't have
the research on this but I could see it
being either way that the yeah like the
the the public facing hey we're just
trying to protect them but behind the
scenes guess what we're gonna wear
take their families and see how much
they want to fight once we've got their
families and that is jacked up and they
admitted that's why they kind of broke
it's one of the major reasons why they
broke true lies true lies one of us yeah
they'll do that Arnold but do they have
Jamie Lee Curtis in the end what do they
do know they took the daughter Oh
isn't in one of the Lethal Weapon movies
too yep yeah you see this is a common
theme rather that's how yeah that's a
good move
really when you think about it it's a
good move yeah it's effective you get
that so that's what I'm saying people
come you know what this is a good move
we're gonna get their families and it's
and it's messed up even if their intent
wasn't to let him die and starve and die
of disease even if their intent was if
we just have your families and that's
just jacked up in its own right mail
boomer prisoners of war generally fare
better than their family since the Army
had at least some experience in this
area and was aiming at reconciliation so
yeah soldiers that go into prisoner of
war at least they understand how to
soldier at least they understand how to
you know clean and in and state
disease-free whereas the families had no
idea by May 1902 after two and a half
years of fighting the cost and morale
physical and monetary terms had made
itself felt on both sides that guerilla
war and inflicted more than twice the
casualties of the conventional phase on
both sides attrition became the critical
factor the deliberate destruction of
30,000 farms
[Music]
hundreds of square miles of farmland
three-or sorry 6.3 million sheep filled
Britain with a sense of guilt the leader
of the Opposition was moved to question
the supposed methods of barbarism in
parliament stripping the country and
only hardened the Boers reserve
concentration camps proved both
expensive and debilitating on the
brittish's will to win so you know this
is sort of like a Vietnam situation
where
the people back in America are looking
at what's going on in Vietnam and seeing
and seeing it as a nightmare mm-hmm and
that's sort of what they're saying here
that the British are seeing what's
happening or hearing about what's
happening and they're starting to have a
sense of guilt about it mmm not even the
vast wealth of Britain could sustain the
seemingly endless struggle in South
Africa in the face of increasingly
uneasy domestic and hostile
international opinion so they also got
the world looking at him going what are
you guys doing down there you've got the
you've got the women and children dying
in concentration camps what we're not
okay with that the cumulative effect of
these various factors was to soften the
terms ultimately offer to and accepted
by the Brewers in May of 1902 the
reasons given for their surrender
included the devastation of country fear
of those in concentration camps an
increasingly hostile native population
loss of property and an inability to
keep British prisoners from the British
perspective these were more
psychological than military causes for
victory as late as so think about that
and we've covered that multiple military
strategy tacks it's like you break the
will of the people it's not of hey we
beat you on the battlefield here there
or wherever but when you break their
will psychologically that's how you're
gonna win and that's exactly what
happened to here as late as December
25th 1901 The Times of London still
spoke of large areas of South Africa
where columns of less than 600 men could
be overwhelmed over 21,000 boomers now
laid down their arms to the British a
force equal in numbers to that with
which they started the war of the twenty
four thousand brewers who died in the
war only four thousand could properly be
judged as dying in combat
the remaining 20,000 consisted primarily
of women and children victims of the
camps the British lost twenty-two
thousand men two-thirds of whom died
from disease in the end superior numbers
wealth and will to power had won out in
conjunction conjunction with a radically
formed approach to modern warfare and
and yeah again this is a modern war
where you know you've got civilians
dying it's a freaking nightmare and you
also have the big imperial power with
all the strength and all the might and
all the people and all the supplies you
know kind of coming to a draw with a
bunch of peasants with farmers with
untrained guerrillas you know like we're
gonna see well like we're gonna see in
Vietnam like we're gonna see in
Afghanistan like we're gonna see in Iraq
the last section really gets into how
this how those things that were learned
are put into play and they talk about
Roberts here and and what his emphasis
was on administration and communication
and and actually started bringing naval
officers in to help because naval
officers had a good reputation for being
you know good at communication good
administration you know that the Navy
the Navy is a very logistical II heavy
organization you've got ships at sea
they have to be fuel do you have sailors
on board that need to be fed like
there's a administrative part of it that
is incredibly challenging and you got to
do all this while you're on the ocean
mm-hmm so they're good at that the Navy
is very good at that Roberts also
eliminated outdated exams and and
encouraged personal evaluation of senior
officers in for in order to get people
advanced so that was solid
greater importance was placed on
fieldwork during the increasing numbers
of maneuvers held in the decade after
the war so after the war they're looking
around gone we better train we better
fix the way we're training and we better
fix who we're putting into these good
positions these officer positions who we
put in there it was claimed that of the
forty thousand dead or wounded suffered
by both sides in the war only fifty were
a result of the sword or the lance in
the light of the Dickinson's committees
finding that a more prominent position
must be given to the training of cavalry
soldier in the use of the fire weapon a
carbine despite its greater lighter
weight gave way to the longer ranged
lee-enfield short rifle and the british
thus became the only rifle armed cavalry
in europe in 1914 the survival as the of
the sword as a secondary weapon so they
kept they kept they kept the sword on
hand hmm listen to this you know that
term stick-in-the-mud yeah like all that
guys I stick in the mud and he doesn't
want to change no it doesn't want to
change
hey he's hey we're doing this knew we'd
always start working you know go go plot
I like I like to stick with the old
stuff you know like stick-in-the-mud
they don't want to change holy cow I
thought that meant useless like this
whole time Oh No just get the muck in
the mud yeah stick in the mud means you
don't want to change the survival of the
sword as a secondary weapon was a
testament to its original pervasiveness
and the disinclination to waste all the
material and training previously
invested so they'll also have what's
that bias called mr. bias which one you
invested a lot into house orders that no
lost investment bias Oh sunk cost
fallacy so here we go they invest they
bought all these swords and then they
trained all these people on how to use
the swords they're like hey we bought
him when we trained people we're gonna
stick with it was claimed that the Lance
interfered with a very cavalry func
function saved the charge for encumbered
dismounting firing and concealment
regarded as inferior to the sward in
protracted melees and difficult to
master when little time or money could
be spared for a third weapon the Lance
was consigned to the dustbin of history
maintenance of the sword on the other
hand rested upon tradition its cheapness
as compared to a pistol and the fact
was always loaded like I can I can I can
put myself in the room to the military
group that's sitting around talking of
discussing should we get pistols or
should we give swords and someone's
someone's in the back you know some
old-school guys in the back saying we're
gonna give these another gun they
already have a gun what happens if they
run out of bullets you know what happens
if they need to take time to load that
thing your sword is always looted you
know yeah well you can't really argue
with that and the old man in the back
wins keep we keep making swords and keep
training people in the swords so I
thought that that was interesting we
also have a section here saying in snow
fog and dusk or dawn the the they still
thought that the sword could win battles
how big is that sword I don't know
probably just the normal length you
think a sword to be like you don't look
for three or four feet yeah
no no seems big I have a Navy sword
seems cumbersome it's ceremonial yeah
you don't think carry it around though
right I think not I carry my sword into
combat yeah the return to more
traditional cavalry tactics was fraught
with difficulties years of training led
to broad fronted attacks to avoid
concentric fire concentric fire meaning
were surrounding the area and we're
starting to half blue-on-blue situations
taking place by 1911 it was clear that
the reactionaries had won the day in the
matter of cavalry tactics other armies
constricted conscript infantry it was
bleed could never stand to charge
that's an arrogant statement hey look we
will continue to do these mounted
charges because a bunch of conscripts
draftees they're not gonna withstand a
charge you can hear the British talking
about no no one would be able to
withstand one of our charges a bunch of
conscripts furthermore faith was placed
in tactical imponderables such as
ammunition giving out or that some local
condition would lead to surprise or a
major battlefield role despite evidence
to the contrary provided by the Boer
so they they would they would still talk
I I've been in so many of these
conversations as things start to new
tactics come out I've been in so many of
these conversations cuz I was in
training for a long time I mean I was in
training as a as a young enlisted seal
for I don't know a couple years I was at
at training sell at SEAL team one which
was a good crew of guys Master Chief
faculty was in charge
it was just legit but you know we had
all these little discussions some new
tactic or whatever and then once the war
started it was on because now we had to
make sure we figured out our tactics and
make them right and there is always you
know people with differing opinions I'll
tell you what I used to sit I probably
pulled so much leadership understanding
from sitting in those meetings and not
saying anything just seeing two people
dig in then get in a fight over should
you do this or should you do that
like it that's why these as I hear these
things being talked about
I can I can picture it you know I can
picture someone saying there's no way
and could stand a charge from all
cavalry unit possible to think because
you do think that you know you know what
else this happens you ever uh like like
I'll shoot I've trained fighters and you
think there's no way that this could
ever happen mm-hmm and sure enough it
happens because it's a fight yeah
anything can happen in a fight we more
wild the you know how like when someone
does like a self-defense demonstration
it's like sure okay someone's holding
your neck here saying you hit them to
the ribcage and that'll bring their
hands down here right so it like their
whole instruction or demonstration kind
of realize up on the enemy to react or
not withstand certain charges that
you're throwing at them you know and so
and then you compare it to like a real
fight or whatever like everyone said
well yeah like you'll hit a guy in his
liver and his hands will
all the way downhill recoil in this like
way or whatever but yeah every once in a
while but proud hardly ever really when
you consider how many punches and kicks
are thrown to the to the ribs you don't
totally it's like bruh that's not gonna
happen and here's what's even worse than
that when I say to you hey you when you
grab me by the neck and I punch you in
the ribs your grip is gonna get loose
for a second and then you say well it
might not and I go okay hold my neck and
then I just punch you in the ribs
and you know cuz we're not in a fight
we're just kind of standing there and I
catch you off guard and punch you the
ribs you know I give you a nice body
shot yeah yeah your hands gonna let
loose but you're not trying to kill me
at that moment you're you're got you
weren't even ready for it
and so therefore I reinforce the idea
it's like if the in this situation I've
said okay I'll tell you what mate I'll
tell you what why don't you go down
there and stand with your troops and I'm
just gonna charge you and see who can
stand there it's no one's gonna stand
there yeah I remember my wife's brother
one time I don't know if he was just
openly refuting the effectiveness of
jujitsu or what but he was like he like
basically like I just do pressure points
on you oh yeah but not the kind I'm
gonna hit you and I know is that like
I'm gonna put my finger on you in mock
yeah you know all these things and then
so you kind of think like first off like
you kind of consider it for a second you
know like man what if you what if he
does really put it the pressure point on
me or whatever and I'm thinking okay all
the times I've been training and
competing or whatever like what if
someone put a pressure point on me like
doing juju
I don't think I would ever I don't think
you'd even feel it in a competition
that's what I'm thinking right like even
the most I mean really what's a pressure
point the one behind your ear you know
your jaw and like these other he did one
like why my neck interesting sounds like
okay and I realized I get Brad you won't
feel pressure points when you're for
real fighting so I was like all right
even when you're just training yeah
right you're not gonna feel that so I
was like I do it and I just I was like
okay like we're kind of fight
just in my mind I wasn't getting like
fired up outwardly or nothing and did it
I was like Oh pressure point and brats
all you have to do is be like okay this
pressure point is dumb and then when he
puts it on you don't feel it but put it
this way like if I'm just cruising next
to you or something even like you and I
start like digging into the back here
you're gonna be like oh it's just gonna
make you move just cause it's like
probably your mine's not like on that
thing right now I had a guy this was for
this was I might have been trained in
jiu-jitsu for like hmm maybe six months
and I had that remember this term
traditional martial artist yeah man oh I
forgot about the idea front about the
abbreviation so I had a traditional
martial artist who is talking me about
well you know I pressure point this and
you know this Beauvoir and of course bro
you think I'm fired up for jujitsu now
you see me I'm fired up I was for
jujitsu when I'd been training for six
months I mean I was ready to rock and
roll at any time and so this guy who he
was a seal to and you know he you know
you know he had like the whole thing
going on the whole kind of you know
mystical sort of vibe you know talking
about how well and you know what I'm
saying
I have no mystical vibe whatsoever I'm
like let's fight yeah that doesn't so
let's fight yes sir and and we actually
in this particular situation we were I
had mats because as soon as I started
training that I got mats so I had mats
well three feet outside of my office in
the day and where I was working at the
time so you know he starts talking this
time like hey let's fight okay so cool
and I think I actually started in the
bottom on the bottom and he tried to
pressure point my neck you know my neck
and I arm locked the [__] out of him you
know just you know he's in my guard he's
giving me you can't give you can't
deliver anyone a more beautiful arm lock
than
holding your arms straight on their neck
and trying to dig your thumb into their
trachea or whatever whatever the
pressure point is yeah and of course I
was like wow you know I made like a face
like it like I cared and then just slap
this psycho arm lock on and yeah that
was my the end of my belief and pressure
points yeah they would you know there'd
always be guys that would have they some
of the prisoner handling techniques
would be what they call it they called
it pain compliance oh yeah oh yeah do
this like under your nose but you know
above your lip and above under your nose
oh you'll make feel but man if you're at
all fired up to use your term right you
can just grit through that you know and
it's different cuz if you have--if
because they used to use that if you
want to choke someone you put your
finger in a nose and you can lift their
chin yeah try that to somebody that's
angry ya know what you have to do is and
what what's lame is all you have to do
is actually just choke their face you
just put a rear-naked choke on their
face and then it'll open up and you'll
crush their John it's all nasty and it
hurts that's pain compliance yeah and so
yeah when you kind of think about it cuz
like you're right like okay so doing
that let the nose thing like when you
want to let it you or not oh yeah I do
that did you go down Jiu Jitsu yeah in
it it does work in jujitsu in training
yeah it's working competition too but
your you make a good point when you say
try do it to someone who's mad yeah
usually even in competition people
aren't mad you know it's like it's like
a sport like it even feels like a sport
especially the more you train like in
the beginning it kind of feels like a
little fight whatever but in training
it'll work because you're not you no
one's mad it's like oh oh that's like
that's more pain then this whole role
has presented so like your head just
kind of naturally does it but if you're
mad or if you're ready for it like if
someone's like oh I know this guy always
does this and you don't let it affect
you it won't affect you here's what's
really jacked up it you know you and I
both pretty much agree that it doesn't
work if you're mad and when it happens
to you you give you so it works even
less
yeah yeah yeah I see that little little
sequence for sure continuing forward
volley fire was obsolete as a
skirmishing infantry were now limited to
using it only as ranging techniques
reconnaissance observation dispersion
and above all marksmanship were now
stressed so this is still right after
the war Roberts the ever proponent of
marksmanship eliminated the old bullseye
and replaced it with modern smaller
moving and disappearing head and
shoulder targets that appeared at
unknown ranges and forced the men to
judge distance for themselves
by 1907 the qualification involved 180
shots over half of which were at ranges
of between 300 and 600 yards so that's
awesome that's that's an incredible
improvement to go from shooting
bull's-eyes and you know I always heard
that this came in America after World
War one that that's when they started
shooting so man saved silhouette targets
and moving targets but here you go this
is pre-world War one had the British
responded to increasing firepower by a
recourse to harsher discipline and a
ready acceptance of higher losses as did
some of their continental brethren they
would no doubt have evolved a different
set of principles so so the British
instead of responding to increasing
firepower by harsher discipline because
you know what I could say as a leader is
hey when the machine gun shoots we need
to go and when it doesn't work we go
harder and it's still not gonna work
that's what some of the Continentals did
so as it was they preferred to recast
their system into a more intelligent
less mechanical soldier II following
Roberts dictates first proclaimed in
November of 1900 the British solution
was a reasoned response to the
realisation in South Africa that
officers could no longer be heard and
dared not be conspicuous
this is just such an important aspect
every aspect of modern warfare
emphasized the individual dispersion
which means spreading out independent
fire which means pit selecting your own
targets use of cover which is sacred
inner minute rushes which means we're
gonna go whenever we feel like it's the
right time to go not just when everyone
tells us to go not just when we're
ordered to go and the sheer scale and
intensity of the battle the greater
psychological isolation on the
battlefield had to be overcome so that
the loss of five men and twenty five
advancing over two hundred fifty yard
would hardly stop in advance while it
was known that fifty out of 250 would so
this is just this this whole little
paragraph is is so important to
understand that the British had learned
lessons and had actually come up with an
effective way of fighting in a modern
way an indication of the new British
attitude was the substitution of
infantry training for infantry drill in
the 1902 manual the combined training
manual which applied to all ranks
addressed this issue directly success in
war and here does success in war cannot
be expected unless all ranks have been
trained in peace to use their wits we
want people to think generals and
commanding officers are therefore not
only to encourage their subordinates in
doing so by affording them constant
opportunities of acting on their own
responsibilities they will also check
all practices so that mean stop all
practices which interfere with the free
exercise of judgment and will break down
by every means in their power the
paralyzing habit of an unreasoning and
mechanical adherence to the letter of
orders and to routine when acting under
service conditions and you believe that
that's that's what we talk about all the
time as we talk about time at Ashkelon
front that's what decentralized command
is every leader is
thinking person we want everybody to
lead that's what they're talking about
we want to set a culture where if you
where we want you to think outside the
box and we want to stop anything that
prevents people from making decisions
and showing initiative captains so
that's a pretty low ranking officer were
not only granted more independence but
we're also forced to take a hand in the
education of subalterns a role
traditionally managed by the colonel so
now we're looking at our our captain's
and saying you better train these young
lieutenants get them up to speed with
anticipate with the anticipated
isolation of the battlefield and just to
re-emphasize what they mean by isolation
of the battlefield we're all spread out
there's 300 people over you know a mile
front we are not close to each other so
you get psychological isolation how are
you gonna act when you're alone and you
get the actual isolation of being
separated from maybe from the other
people that are with you maybe from your
squad but definitely from the senior
leadership with the anticipated
isolation the battlefield and constantly
intermingled lines it seemed a necessity
to develop informed and assured officers
to prevent rearward drift smaller
British companies with 120 men as
compared to Continental units twice
their size seemed especially well-suited
to increased individual training now
requires they made the unit's a little
bit smaller key elements of new training
for infantrymen included practice at
various intervals and pacing accuracy of
maintained Direction use of cover and
independent fire familiarize Asian with
intermixed units and the development and
acceptance of interchangeable command
necessitated by casualties sustained
above among leaders this is everything
we used to run and trade it no we're
gonna put all your leaders down you're
gonna use cover you're gonna use
independent fire you're gonna mix up
your units the post-war developments
entire thrust was toward a
simplification of techniques that would
allow for mastery by the lowest ranking
soldier keeping things simple
the provisional infantry manual of 1902
went so far as to eliminate several
traditional drill positions and all
field bugle call
except the charge so they're getting rid
of the reason you have a field bugle
call is so that you can tell a mass of
people to do everything at the same time
and they're getting rid of all those to
say hey individual leader you know
subordinate leaders out there make
things happen the only one they keep is
the charge and why is that probably
because that British bravado and courage
is still is still a real thing and
because if you have one emergency
situation you want to at least be able
to say hey look we better freakin just
charge hit the call physical and bayonet
drills were brought down to the squad
level and the company replaced the
battalion as the training tactical unit
since it was regarded as the largest
force command of all by an individual
under battle conditions so they used to
try and direct 500 or 700 people by one
man now they're down to a company of 120
the new manual stressed the many lessons
of the war and was so recognized even at
the time noted for example the tasks
allotted infantry upon the occupation of
a position a forward placement of
skirmishers with an eye to maximizing
firepower camouflage utilizations of
rests determination of ranges and
clearing of fire zones so many tasks on
so lower-level necessitated necessitated
a soldier who could think for himself
all those things we still do those
things we get into a position we get
into a perimeter machine gunners are
checking out therefore they're getting
in position they're camouflaging
themselves they're getting covered
position you've got the the the point
man figuring out where the extract will
be everyone's doing this stuff
decentralized so many tasks on so low a
level that's what we're talking about
but the initiative the emphasis impetus
toward greater initiative by all ranks
intent in the tactical sphere was one of
relatively short duration as military
emphasis began to shift toward
continental warfare so you had all these
great changes taking place the lessons
learned from the Boer War and they
started to get influenced by they
started to get influenced by what the
Continental Army's were doing the French
the Germans the Russians which was the
old-school stuff
the newer tactics were based on the
belief that success in war depends on
morale depends more on morale than on
physical qualities say the same thing so
they're saying look it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter these little running
around in skirmish lines and all that
and taking cover that's not what's
important what's important is the morale
skill this is what they thought skill
this is a quote skill cannot compensate
for want of courage energy and
determination boy is that a lie no one
wants to hear this that's a lie hmm yeah
you think your skill that's like the
tough-guy right that rolls into the gym
they do this is you have a courageous
guy rolling it off the street you know
he's courageous he's fired up so he has
energy he's super determined
I'll take someone in here yeah cool row
with Jeffy Glover over there yeah guys
will say that too right like I don't
care how trained you are like I'm like
ferocious oh yeah I used to be I mean
there was all there was definitely a
time when that was a much more prominent
thought right well if you really went
down yeah bro I would just get nuts on
you yeah you know and you're looking at
him going I'll tell you what once you
get nuts right now well and you know
when you really think about it though
it's like okay you can kind of
understand why someone who doesn't know
any better
would think that because remember back
in the day when you're like a little kid
and the guy can be bigger than you but
you know why I mean I'm sure they say
they have an expression in Hawaiian they
call it MV now so if you just amp out on
a guy yeah you can you could take them
for a couple of reasons one you're just
going like you feel less pain and
just going in whatever you have all this
crazy energy or whatever well you know
what that is that's surprised violence
of action yes oh yeah you're gonna get
nuts yeah nothing yeah I'm gonna amp out
on the dude it's gonna be surprised
gonna be violence of action you're gonna
get the upper the tactical upper hand
and now this dude's days and that's how
you win that is a factual thing and you
just go and yeah and you can even get to
a factual thing with two untrained right
I just realized hey I just said that's a
factual thing and it sounded like I was
saying that that would work it works if
you're not if you're going against
someone that's equally as untrained as
your dumb ass is exactly right and
that's the point so you get a guy off
the street Brad that's usually how they
are they don't know they have no idea
what like train they think that if you
get a choke on them that they did some
sneak attack lucky thing or something
like that's what I feel that they just
don't know so yeah make sense that they
think that you know you can kind of
understand that's where let's go again
comes from yeah a big thing when
someone's I go to old I'll take that
jujitsu stuff whatever you know it's not
gonna work on me core you choke him and
then they get up and they go whoa let's
go again yeah cool let's go again yeah
you know those those Gracie in action
videos or those like that was how broad
they the end the guy was like they'd be
like oh let's go get I just need to just
go harder yeah better literally what
they'd say it's like the same deal the
same deal the same deal the after always
the same I can't you know can't do
nothing you know why though and I
remembered I remembered this to wear you
know before you know jujitsu and someone
winds up in a good position in a big
scramble in a real fight and you just
wind up in this weird and they get you
deep in some headlock or something like
that right because you were just
scrambling in whatever you wound up in a
headlock a lot of times
jujitsu positions feel like randomly
like landed on positions if you don't
know jujitsu so someone has you like in
the mount or on your back or whatever
and you feel like real like kind of
helpless you're like oh this seems like
we just sort of landed here you know so
if I just go harder and maybe keep my
eyes open a little bit better oh yeah
yeah yeah
you're saying for the victim of jujitsu
yeah that person doesn't understand that
the position that you ended up in is a
position that you know very you dictate
deliberate yes very on that it has an
outcome the Oya which is known yes
exactly right but yeah if you don't know
jiu-jitsu it feels like oh he we just
sort of wound up there cuz you don't
have like Judas is like this man if you
know the map and I talk about this like
you know if we're talking to people who
don't have training it the map of
jiu-jitsu side mount mount guard likes
half guard like all this stuff or
whatever super clear when you know you
just super clear you know exactly where
you are at pretty much every moment of a
jujitsu situation winning or losing but
if you don't know jiu-jitsu it all just
seems like kind of like a whirlwind like
yeah somebody oh do you remember like if
your leg was over his leg or under he
would have no idea about but if you're
if you know Jiu Jitsu you'd be like no I
remember one leg was over one leg was
under whose total half guard situation
you think I don't there's a lot of
things that I don't remember
I do remember every single position for
sure and you know it's cool when I would
train young leaders and see leaders and
put them through dynamic situations
where they had to make calls and make
decisions and is this exact same thing
you know and I'd say well where were you
getting shot at from was it from this
building of this building and they would
have no idea or you know where did you
place your machine gunners they would
have no idea what happened or do you
think you have all your people and they
would have no idea and then the better
that they got the more training we put
them through the more they understood
the positions the more they would
recollect what was happening the more
they could see what was actually
happening as it was happening and that's
the way you need to train the more time
you spend training for these pressure
situations the more you're gonna see the
better control you're gonna have the
better mind control you're gonna have
because that's a whole part of it you
know that's one of the best reasons for
jiu-jitsu being so good for self-defense
is you you're used to getting you used
to having somebody grab ahold of you and
grind on your free
head in a grabbed hold of you that's why
also you need to spend some time boxing
and doing my tie because if you don't
know what that little crack feels like
and it happens to you for the first time
you're gonna you're gonna get you're
gonna get beat down yeah yeah especially
in the face oh yeah get someone punch
you in the nose or whatever it's like
well it's like kinda it's it's not
nothing there's a jam you up for sure ya
gots to be careful continue on new
criteria had to had to be drawn as to
which qualities were desired in the
infantry by 1906 Ian Hamilton and you
got to read the book if you wanna get
all the background on Ian Hamilton was
unfavorably ik weighting initiative and
intelligence with smartness on the
parade field as a cause of rapidity and
cohesion of movement all and so what
he's saying is hey initiative and
intelligence is kind of moving us away
from cohesion when we're when we're on
the dirt when were on the drill field
another guy Hague's belief that the war
of masses necessitates mass tactics led
to a tightening up of british formations
to mean a density of one man per yard in
an advancing line by 1911 so we can see
that this is a nightmare so this guy is
saying this guy Haig is saying hey mass
Matt war of masses means mass tactics we
need to function together and that leads
to if we're gonna function together we
better be close together to the tune of
one man per yard that's a nightmare this
in turn was recognized as an
overreaction to the South African
extension since it seemed far easier to
concentrate men on the battlefield than
to spread them out this is what we call
modern day dispersion you got to spread
out and I wrote about and leadership
strategy and tactics there's all these
different reasons why you want to get
close to someone else when you're when
there's shooting going on all kinds of
reasons subconscious reasons actual
tackle like I want to hear what you say
I'm a little bit nervous I want to get
close to you we stick together and all
those things all of a sudden you look at
look around you you got five six seven
eight guys right next to you and doesn't
know it's not good mmm one grenade one
machine-gun fire can can take you all
out or at least several of you out and
it's already hard to fight it but when
you go into the battle situation already
tight grouped it's gonna be a it's gonna
not work out well the French and then
the British began to consider frontal
attacks the most decisive of all so you
see word now this is again this is like
1911 they're starting to regress this
regressive fury was given official
sanction in the 1912 FS r which Field
Service regulations and marked the
greatest split with the Boer War
experience whereas the Boer War led
primarily to a modern approach to
warfare downgrading battlefield cavalry
and fostering initiative and firepower
Manchuria proved regressive and so what
Manchuria is the jet the russo-japanese
war which was the another big war that
took place and they were using the
old-school tactics but they were also
fighting old school against old school
and they were both playing by the rules
so if you and I decide to have a war of
attrition if you and I decide hey we're
gonna have a boxing match and the rules
are we can only punch then we stand
there and punch each other in the head
and if you're bigger and stronger than
me then you can win and if and so won't
what and so that it looks like you're
better than me right hey you're bigger
and stronger than me and you will beat
me and we bring on the next challenger
and you're bigger and stronger than him
and you beat him and then we bring in a
300-pound guy and he's bigger than you
and he beats you mm-hm how did he beat
you he was bigger and stronger but he
used the same tactics but he was just
bigger and stronger so what are we gonna
do we're gonna make our military our
groups been
you're in stronger what happens when you
go out and throw a punch and someone
does a double leg takedown put you on
the ground get side control gets
Mountain and chokes you don't matter how
big that person is simplicity and
elasticity of movement were among the
prime lessons of South Africa formalism
was on its way out but individual
responsibility was still quite a way off
so this this part here runs through a
little bit of timeline that we've been
tripping through I've been kind of
jumping around a little bit by 1904 both
the scale and comfortable going back to
1904 by 1904 both the scale and
complexity of military exercises had
increased for the first time the Army
and the Navy cooperated in trial
invasion and Rhee embarked Asian under
fire the troops were now four by now
scarcely visible so they were that were
using camouflage they were hiding by
virtue of improved technique and
equipment no attack on entrenchments was
considered successful at odds of less
than six to one and there was no volley
fire so that des 1904 by 1905 maneuver
battalion and Brigade training had
become considerably more decentralized
increasing responsibility flowing
registers so so 2005 our sorry 1905 were
still moving in the right direction 1906
exercises featured controversies over
the effectiveness of machine guns so now
as we start this is like traditional
martial arts and and someone saying hey
man if you get if you get punched in the
face you'll give this reaction and
someone saying well with machine guns
you'll have this reaction people are
saying well I don't know about that hmm
right so now they're having a little
debate about what's gonna work and
what's not gonna work
19:07 experience was marked by
complaints from the territorials that
despite expectations of their ability to
perform on a divisional level they never
trained as such so so now we're starting
to see that the trainings fallen off
maybe a little bit 1908 the problem a
consistent of mobilization and
concentration of an entire army of four
divisions attached cavalry ancillary
services in a friendly area senior roles
the roles of senior personnel large
formations and logistics were coming the
force and now they're focused on the big
move
the big logistics in deference to
private property which is where they
were running these big exercises tapes
were laid down to demonstrate position
so that their descent a this is our
position lay down some tape here because
they didn't want to dig in because it's
private property
far more would have been achieved
without actual digging but that had to
await to the acquisition of larger
government-owned training areas 1909 the
maneuvers marked a contrast to those of
1904 to 1906 as the infantry was
adopting appreciably denser formations
so that going backwards denser formation
last aspersion greater commitment to
reserves and more emphasis on the
counter-attack by 1910 there could be
little doubt that the british tactical
Prak practice --is had largely drifted
from those evolved during the Boer War
to those of the more conservative French
the memorandum on Army Training 1910
emphasized winning the preparatory
action through strong advance guards to
be followed by a commitment of a central
reserve central reserve this is a
commander's in the back and he's he's
gonna commit the central reserve under
the direct control of the commander who
was to apply them at the decisive point
as part of a prepared plan you see where
this is going we're doing kata mmm we're
doing kata this is what we're gonna do
this is the plan once you hit here then
you follow up with this it's all
prepared yeah and that's another thing
it reminded me of like when I when I
talk about that martial arts and
demonstration when they demonstrate on
an actual like victim right or it's like
you're gonna hit him here in the ribs
their hands or their hands and they
buckle over you know when you employee
you know employ the knee you know here
and whatever it's not only that they're
predicting the other guys movement it's
they're predicting it and then their
next move is dependent on that very
prediction yes so when it like doesn't
happen in real life it's like man old
Jamie up big time you
and this and this is actually the last
section of this book we're gonna read
the last thing and this supports what
you just said concentrations were to be
completed before and not during the
battle meaning we already know what
we're gonna do and we're not gonna make
adjustments which is which is the idea
that you're talking about this idea that
this is what we're gonna do this is the
reaction we're gonna have and the the
Mike Tyson statement of no survived no
plan survives the first punch in the
face the common military which is no
plan survives the first enemy contact
that idea is thrown away and we've
gotten to a point through doing these
fake you know drills where you start
believing your own ideas they don't work
this is why when we started using
simunition and in paintball in our SEAL
training we started changing the way we
were doing business because when we
started that it was in like 1990 to 1993
and they uses a little bit in the 80s
but on a broad level to actually go to
you know to run drill after drill
iteration after iteration really didn't
start until the 90s and then it really
took hold after after the war started
because then people said wait a second
this is more the the drills that we did
with paintball and with simunition when
with the war started they were they were
validated even more
it wasn't the opposite you might think
well you know once the war started the
real bullets started flying the the
things got more validated and what's
what's horrible about reading this and
seeing the seeing the regression is that
we know where it leads and we know that
it leads to World War one we know that
it leads to trenches we know that it
leads to not a knot maneuver warfare but
two attrition warfare we know that it
leads to 10
million ten million military deaths and
seven million civilian deaths that's
that's where all this goes because we
didn't learn from history we let
arrogance get in the way and you know
like I was saying with the two people
deciding to fight right it's the Russo
the russo-japanese war I if you and I
both let's say have conservative minds
and we're kind of stuck in the past
we're both the stick in the mud that's
okay right that's what we're gonna do
you and I are gonna stand there we're
gonna go blow for blow we're gonna box
that's what we're gonna do and and
that's what that's what the Brits were
kind of looking around the world say
saying oh you see boxing does work
mm-hmm
because look how the Russians fared here
and look at how of the Japanese fared
here we we see that boxing does see what
happened over there mm-hmm but it
doesn't mean that grappling doesn't work
it just means that you're not paying
attention to it means that they decided
that they were gonna box and if if you
decide you're gonna box guess what
you're gonna get punched in the head a
lot and when you come against a force
that's equal to yours it is gonna be
very very hard to overcome them without
taking massive damage and that is World
War one and we need to make sure that we
don't let that happen
to test yourself evolve in every aspect
of your life test yourself evolve make
sure that you are making progress make
sure that you are continuing to learn
and continue to progress and not regress
and with that echo Charles if we want to
continue to learn if we want to progress
rather than regress what do you got for
us progress always get better always
progress try to step forward not
backward stay in the game get in the
game stay in the game get in the game
stay in the game that's it anyway we do
that by what working out we're working
out we're doing jiu-jitsu
we are eating healthy guess what you
know you know how people sometimes go
hey you know echo Charles what did you
learn what have you learned from Jocko
over you know I passed five years doing
this right yeah you know the first thing
that I learned from you what's that you
want to know what it is you said
exercise is the singular thing that will
impact the most aspects of your life and
I never really thought of that before
maybe because I was too close to it and
exercises just kind of part of been part
of my whole adult life and much of my
youth was like focused around exercise
but when you said that and you laid out
hey it helps you hear it helps you there
it helps you somewhere else I recognized
yes this is a something I had never
really thought of I never thought of the
impact because I because exercise was
just part of my life I never thought of
the positive impact that it had on my
life but when you pointed out that
exercise is the most universally
complimentary thing that you can do for
your life and and look there's people
right now okay idiots you know would you
say well you you meathead saying that
which we take as a compliment but a
meathead saying that right
you think exercise is gonna you know
what exercise is gonna is gonna so when
you when you kind of go oh you know we
want to work out like now think about
what I think about how that impacts
every part of your life get in the gym
start lifting start training start
working out run
to swim do calisthenics get after it man
it's gonna make your whole life better
you know it is true little interlude
yeah no I ain't yeah fully and man it's
like okay so we're in quarantine 2020
mm-hmm
right now so you can kind of fall into a
thing I mean if you're really in touch
with like your feelings or whatever like
sometimes you feel kind of stale like
inside because you're not out you're not
doing anything or and not only you're
not out do anything you're not I don't
do anything for kind of extended periods
of time yeah you know some some people
straight up haven't left their house
months haven't left the house so that
can like weigh on you of course
psychologically but I think it's like
physiologically to like in your brain
like chemically it it gotta have some
kind of weird effect definitely I think
that's scientifically proven that
there's some kind of weird effect I
think that's actually the literature
that I read there were some kind of
weird effect oh good obviously I don't
know the literature but I know the
feeling so like the other day right
where I was like in Saigon focusing you
know doing some stuff on my computer for
a long time and I felt like off I didn't
feel good and not to mention there's
some negativity out there and didn't
teach straight yeah right now so man I
was feeling like off like man I don't
know man is this all worth it I don't
know what it really meant by thinking
that but it was those types of feelings
you know I was like man I'm gonna go
outside and my home gym is outside
that's a little covering there it's cool
it's nice but it's outside nonetheless
so I go outside and I feel like the Sun
okay you know it's cool something to the
Sun but I'm still kind of feeling it
bride did my first two sets which are
warm-up sets by the way and he was like
my brain just like switched back on to
like living mode like all that life is
like here now here's the problem with
that the problem with that is that a lot
of people don't make the transition to
the gym you know that's the hard once
they get there if they know they're
gonna feel better oh yeah and if they
don't know they feel better they should
know that they're gonna feel better yeah
but they don't like your at least have
that fought in your mind you know you
kind of know you kind of know sometimes
yeah I feel I don't feel you felt off
yeah we kind of know that to feel on you
got to go out there and just Jack some
steel yeah it's true right well okay so
when you do lift weights and you have to
lift weights a certain like intensity or
whatever and it's pretty low especially
if you're used to lifting weights is
pretty low intensity that you have to
pass that threshold that it'll trigger a
biological physiological response that
is positive yeah so our fans and there's
other things but but these are I always
hear like when people the way some
people you know Matt whatever not
everybody but some people the way they
use endorphins almost like it's like
this just throw away term like your
friends you just sort of feel better in
this and like ambiguous sort of way but
it's a real thing real fur it's like
make sure you like like just like
depression is a real thing like the
opposite of depression like that boost
you get from working out is literally
we're a real thing oh yeah
so yeah the critical and then consider
that notion that affects everything you
do so if you if you're a stronger
healthier and have a better attitude I
don't know one thing maybe I could think
of one but right now I'll talk my head I
don't know one thing that that won't
improve like it's like tangibly
measurably improve totally good to go
oh yeah so anyway yeah so we want to be
working we want to be working a hundred
percent which means we're gonna need
some fuel we will need for sure so we
gotta eat right but supplementation
supplementation if you're into it and
here's the thing there's all kinds of
supplementation here's it might be any
most important type of supplementation
currently for me and I do I am one of
those people who like I would I do wish
I was on this train be like a while ago
before I ended up getting on it so this
is the kind of fuel we like jockle fuel
Jaco feel right anyway joint warfare for
your joints krill oil for your joints
and
antioxidants in their general health
this is like life this is gonna help you
for sure
omega-3s all day also discipline and
discipline go kind of the same thing
yeah actually yeah we have some options
there to kind of get you up on step
whether it's the powder discipline go
choco Palmer iced tea lemonade mix every
day discipline going to can you got that
we just came out with the D yeah wait
vitamin D oh yeah just came out with a D
uh yeah that's where you're going you
were talking about sunshine well that's
true that's a that's a big yeah
sometimes we have to kind of fake that
sunshine a little bit get that vitamin D
but one of the reasons I made the
vitamin D is cuz I did my blood work
area I was lacking the vitamin D so
guess what I know I'm not the only
person I'm living a healthy lifestyle
I'm I live in San Diego sunny San Diego
I surf I'm outside I shoot my bow
outside I run outside you know I'm in
the Sun and I still had so guess what I
know there's other people that need to
get on the D yes the D train you just
saw some vitamin D bulk but by the way
one thing I know you look at situations
they put you in a certain scenario you
want to take advantage of it how's the
Molk train recipes going in your house
because my house because both my
daughters are home from college they're
on the mo yeah they're making all kinds
of stuff with milk yeah raw milk that
put it in everything I never tried the
wrong oh yeah you well it doesn't taste
like anything it's just it just gives
you protein but you can put it in
whatever you wants like a cool little
bit yeah
yeah I'm Justine is that sweet monk
fruit or anything like this justice
proclaimed plaintiff but you can put it
you know my middle daughter she likes to
make some smoothies with fruit you know
put the blueberries oh no she's doing
all kinds of radical things Oh No
just different kind of milks and stuff
and so she's on that wrong wrong train
my son on the other hand he told me that
the best flavor which this was weird is
the darkness yes I understand that's
what he's down with right now yeah so he
mixed one up this morning as I was on my
way here and I took a little heater of
course I don't know if it was like this
what do you have you have your twin
brother Jade you got your little brother
mm-hm kidnapped uh and then you have
your sister I have an older sister okay
did you guys fight and like wanna stab
each other when it came to food at all
no okay so that's what I was like in my
family when I was growing up and my kids
absolutely everyone is ultra like dog
Wolfpack protective of their own food so
you know I love my son was mixed up the
darkness he put he put it down on the
counter when he was gonna turn around
and kind of put the stuff away and he
saw that I was in the vicinity and he
immediately turned back around and
grabbed it he got into his own
protective custody and I looked at him
and said give me some of that milk and
he you know he kind of he recognized
Deebo style
I had a debo his uh his Mulk but I just
had a little hitter and and I kind of
went into an agreement look it's not my
favorite let's let that do its good oh
yeah the dark it's alright anyways get
some milk some strawberry milk some mint
milk some some peanut butter get some
chocolate white tea get some get some d3
you can get it all at the vitamin shop
or you can get it online at origin main
dot-com you can also get DS there
jujitsu keys let's face it Judas is
coming back I think it's gonna be like
the economy it's gonna come back even
stronger yes very possible actually that
seems to be the case even in theory
mm-hmm not to mention my practical
practice but think about it like you
know how like when you take some time
off you want one it's time to go back
here like oh man I can't wait to get
back wow that's the demon tricking
stringing us along for a long time you
know us wanting to get back in stuff so
yeah it's gonna be way
we're strong and that's not to mention
the people who I'm gonna start going to
start juicing I'm gonna start it here
oh I was just gonna start it soon are
they really gonna start pent-up pent-up
demand so just gonna come back strong
these jeans boots t-shirts whatever you
need we're getting there
I mean in America by Italy yeah no big
deal but every single thing I just said
is 100% made in America there's nothing
being imported there's no little parts
to not just be not just flying in a
bunch of parts from all over the world
and sewing them together no they're
growing it and so in it growing in and
finish more Jemaine calm go check it out
and that does provide that support yeah
big turn also more support more items
for to represent and maintain yourself
on the path you know sometimes the way
you say that well I can a lot of things
that you say
especially during this support section
sure you kind of wind it up and you kind
of say it like you're gonna have a new
approach it but there's not that's the
gift that keeps on giving for sure first
time every time as we say in the
industry yeah so I you know when you say
there's clothes that you can represent
and I'm thinking what are you gonna say
it sounds like he's thinking he's making
a move he's gonna try something new
represent wall on the path and I'm okay
I guess we're going with all right so
we're gonna go with you you know away if
you need to represent while on the path
yes sir
oh yeah wait how can you do should we
not represent it while we're on the road
should definitely represent what we can
represent hey that's what I think I
don't know I might be alone yeah but I'm
probably not alone you know why cuz I
see him I see the blue I see the people
you know I see the the people
representing in the wild is what I see
check anyway if you want to represent on
the past in the wild in private wherever
you like Jaakko store.com that's where
you can get your shirts hats hoodies
discipline equals freedom good take the
high ground on the high ground will take
you they've got the truth
it's all there chuckles store calm yeah
man if you see something that you like
get something some patches on there to
women's stuff women's stuff on there to
get something for you know your your
lady uh personnel in whatever capacity
is that in like is that a good personnel
personnel right sure mothers wives
girlfriends daughters cousins that maybe
female neighbors that might be female
represent they can represent - boom all
day anyway yeah chuckles door
also you can subscribe to this podcast
if you feel like it you can do that
wherever you listen to podcast we also
have some other podcast we got the
thread why is it taking so long for me
to figure out the new name for the
thread the reason is because the thread
I like the name and now I want to get
hit with a bolt of lightning for the new
name it hasn't hit me yet normally I get
hit with bolts of lightning you know
it's a rare occasion that you get I
actually get hit but on a fairly regular
basis wack here's a new idea wack here's
a new idea so we're a little bit we're
waiting I got my lightning rod out and
waiting to get cracked but well we'll
bring that back grounded podcast where
we talk about jujitsu warrior kid
podcasts for the warrior kids in your
life and don't forget to give yourself
some warrior kid soap from Irish Oaks
ranch dot-com is that available on
chocolate or calm yes sir
oh is that 100% 100% boom well actually
technically warrior kids soap I think
that's a new one yeah yeah it's coming
out Jocko says doctors are so poor so
kill their soul killer so all their yeah
all different kind of options so that
you your family the people you know you
can all stay clean we got a YouTube
channel yep YouTube video version of
this podcast so you can subscribe to
that yeah if you want if you know if
you're walking down the street and
you're thinking you wish that things
were exploding you're wishing that
things were just shaking you wish that
there was military vehicles smashing
into walls mm-hmm well you can subscribe
to the YouTube channel yeah
you can see all that stuff sure
sometimes and robots robots you know
everyone's on all throw a robot in there
and there's if you want to you can watch
this video there's also little excerpts
that you can if there's a little point
that got made you I'd like to share that
with Fred sure you can share it with
Fred you'll have to share I'm a two hour
and 42 minute podcast you can just give
me 12 minutes maybe 17 minutes cuz echo
doesn't like to edit things down well
he's not gonna make it into a three
minute video club not without putting
some damn Star Wars effects in it yes
sometimes
yes also psychological warfare you know
what that is it's an album tracks yeah
album with tracks Jocko tracks anyway
when you're having moments a weakness
psychological warfare will actually help
you through those moments a weakness as
if Jocko is there personally helping you
through that moment same thing flipside
canvas calm Dakota Meyers to company
he's selling psychological warfare for
your wall check that out
I also got some books we got the code
the evaluation the protocols we got and
that has very direct methodology for you
to grade yourself to for you to know
exactly what you're trying to do to
treatable project your path right your
path follow your path to victory get the
code the evaluation of protocols we got
leadership strategy and tactics Field
Manual we got way the warrior kid one
two and three four all the way of the
warrior for all the warrior kids out
there we also have Mikey and the Dragons
which is just live
teach your kids your young kids how to
overcome fear think of what that does to
a little kids life it changes their life
I get a Mikey and the dragons discipline
equals freedom Field Manual extreme
ownership and that economy leadership
the books that started it all
also we have echelon front which is my
leadership consultancy where we solve
problems through leadership go to
echelon front comm for details if you
want me or one of the guys at epsilon
front to come and talk at your company
or to come and start working with your
company or start consulting at your
company don't go to a speaker's bureau
go to a salon front comm EF online if
you want to interact with me go to EF
online I will be live I am live multiple
times per week pre-scheduled do you come
on you can ask me questions you can ask
the rest of the team questions it's not
overloaded with people it's not like
when I do an Instagram live where
there's 87,000 questions coming in every
second no these are this is much more
controlled so if you want to interact if
you want to ask me a question go to EF
online.com and come and get some also we
have the muster which is our Leadership
Conference our leadership event we're
gonna be in Phoenix Arizona on September
16th and 17th and then we're gonna be in
Dallas Texas December 3rd and 4th
extreme ownership calm if you want to
come every event that we've ever done is
sold out so if you want to come go and
register and of course now we have EF
overwatch if you are in a company and
you want leaders that understand the
principles of extreme ownership that we
talked about here go to EF overwatch
comm and if you're a veteran that wants
to get hired by a company that
understands these principles same thing
back at you if you want to support a
charitable organization go to America's
mighty warriors org it is Mark Lee's mom
mama Lee and she works all the time
tirelessly to help service members their
families gold star families and military
personnel that are deployed around the
world you can go to that website to
either donate or get involved and if you
haven't heard enough
of my monotonous monologues or you need
more of echoes uncoupled orations and
you can find us both on the interwebs on
Twitter on Instagram and on Facebook
echo is that echo Charles and I am at
chakra when Lincoln thanks to our
military men and women who signed on the
dotted line and wrote a check with their
lives in the service of our country and
thanks to police and law enforcement and
firefighters and paramedics and EMTs and
dispatchers and correctional officers
and Border Patrol and Secret Service who
do the same right check with their lives
for our safety here at home and everyone
else out there make sure you build on
your lessons do not regress jack with
the past question what you're doing
pressure test yourself and your methods
question your methods your old methods
your new methods make sure that you
never get complacent and that you never
allow your ego to overrule moving in the
right direction it is easy to slip it's
also easy to think that just because
you're getting after it just cuz you're
training hard just because you're
pushing yourself that you are doing it
correctly
don't settle for that yes get after it
but do so in the smartest possible way
with humility and an open mind to learn
until next time this is echo and Jocko